[Music]
hi I'm Christopher Hine and we're
talking about footwork this week so
that's maybe a little bit of a misnomer
for this video because we're not
strategically talking about footwork in
this video we're gonna talk about the
tie no kinko and the town of Hanko is
the variation position between you and
the other person that could be your
attacker or whatever it is that you need
to position yourself differently to so
Aikido has a set of tie no Hanko that
are key the tiny Lenco are actually the
way we vary the position and then the
new position is a thing unto itself so
we're going to talk a little bit about
the actual positions and then how we
vary the line to get to those different
positions and what that is and so
there's only have a few basic ways we do
this there's 60 no Hanko six position
variations and we can do that from
either an eye hung me or a doctor on me
we'll also talk in this video about what
I and yaku hanmi really are so instead
of just thinking of it as a static
position it's actually a position that's
constantly in flux so I might tell Josh
over here where you talk a little bit
about the tie no hanko both the basic
positions and the variation of positions
themselves hey Josh okay so we're gonna
talk now about the tie no hanko now you
could lumped I know Hank go in with
footwork and we're kind of doing that in
this video just because the the basic
footwork for Aikido is pretty simple so
we got it we got a few extra videos to
fill up this week so we're gonna go
ahead and start to talk about China Hank
oh no tie no Hank oh and ah she's
Tsubaki which is footwork are
interrelated but the difference is ty no
Hanko only happens in relation to
another person while all she samake can
happen totally by yourself so you can do
the basic footwork patterns completely
by yourself but whenever we're talking
about Tai nameko we're talking about
always being in relation to another
person so first let's talk about what
the basic rough positions are so just
just seeing square eye makes you move
that way just a little bit perfect right
there okay so this is one of the worst
positions to be so I'm gonna show you
the absolute worst position for me this
is the worst position for me
now the reason is that guys behind me
terrible all my tools
here Smitty I was gonna hit him or kick
him he's not in the right position for
that if I was gonna use a weapon he's
not in the right position for that in
order to see him I gotta turn around so
this is the worst position I can be
absolutely worse right but this isn't
all that much better so now I could
defend myself but really he can hit as
hard as I can so word the same amount of
power he can hit me every time back as
hard as I kid him
now if he's stronger than me which is
what we're always accounting for in our
context of Aikido is every time I hit
him he's gonna hit me harder so it's a
losing proposition so I can never settle
for this so I want to at least be a
little eschewed from this we call it mu
honey which means no honey I want to be
a little askew now if I were to move
over this way a little bit I instantly
came in to hanmi with Josh and the kind
of economy I came into him with is
called Yahoo hug me so you can see this
is Josh's left foot that's closest to me
right here and this is my right foot so
we're opposite stance now I'm gonna have
Josh go into hanmi just so it's real
easy to see you can see here's a really
clear fund-me plummy just means a half
body position it just goes back to
square you can see I'm no longer all the
way in front of him right so here I'm
squared up with Josh if he's stronger
than me every time I hit him he hits me
back harder I don't want that so I'm
going to trying to prove my position so
this position is a little bit better and
this is honey this is what honey really
is so I am standing in Rockland oh come
on that's my stance if you just looked
at me but when I'm dealing with Josh I
am and hug me now to Josh I'm in a half
body position - Josh
now this honey is called viago honey
it's because my right foots bored and
relative to me Josh's left foots bored
now if I were to bury that position by
going like this now we would be an eye
honey so my left foots forward and
Josh's left foots bored and just goes it
goes until honey for me real quick so
you can see really clearly this is an
eye hunting position go ahead and go
back so if we bury it that way we're
gettin a hug me and it could either be
yaku or I and that just depends on how I
step and I could step two two different
ways for all kinds of different reasons
now if I could manage to get over to the
side of Josh this position gets way
better for me
now the reason is let's move over you're
just
okay so the reason that this is a lot
better position is because this whole
half of Josh's body is the only half he
can really do damage to me with if he
leaves his body like this and reaches
with his other arm he can't even reach
me right so you can't even touch me a
little Oh hit me hard it would be
impossible for him to kick me with that
leg and even if he had a weapon this
would be a really hard cross body shot
for him to make so if this is kind of
hard to understand look again at the
timings video the body timing video and
this will explain to you why this is a
harder position for him so if I could
manage to get all the way side-by-side
you with Josh that would be really great
now in our school we call this heat
though I mean this is the heat don't
mean position I'm side-by-side with John
you know there's a few ways I could be
in this so just like our ioan iacob hug
me for hunting and he'd know i mean we
can be a few different positions so josh
species you can see this is the chill
Kaku position right so like a 90 degree
position to them we're 90 degrees to
each other I could be this way and this
is I keep throwing me
now it's I he throw me because we're
facing the same direction so we're the
same we're fitting we're matching this
is ie throw me if I were to turn around
her to let me have Josh turn around
because I want to hit these microphones
here so if Josh turns around
now we're yeah cooky throw me so we're
side by side but facing opposite
directions that josh is facing that
direction while I'm facing this
direction so this is Yahoo Keith or me
all right now if I were to get to the
best position for me I would be all the
way back here now look remember when I
talked about what the worst position was
for me now josh is in that very very
position with me have you stepped
forward just a little bit josh is in
that very very position right so I'm
behind this is the best position if I
had to be close distance so when more
close I'm always trying to achieve this
position first which is the easy me
position the position that's entered in
behind Josh on made an entry in behind
Joshua now if I'm this way this would be
called i ET me right because I'm facing
the same direction Josh where Finnick
if I was to be back here like this this
would be Yahoo et me so I'm trying to
get out of here and I'm cut in behind
this guy or if I was at a 90 degree
angle this would be choukaku eating me
right baby I'm like this it's like if
you think of our eating me nage this is
generally happens from a choukaku
right that's cuz he's trying to turn
around good all right it's just um
alright so these are the basic
that we're going to use now getting to
the positions is another skill set in
and of itself so that skill set is
actually the tiny link oh so how I vary
those positions so let me have you move
back just a tiny bit alright and put
this foot forward for me all right so
right now Josh and I and we just kind of
fabricated this so it's easy to see and
this is a great way to work with
students on we've ended up in a Yahoo
honey so Josh left foot forward I'm
right foot for it there are only six
ways to begin burying these positions
right so those are either a honey
choukaku right which means half of a 90
degree angle so that's just coming out
of 45 and our school would designate
that byte the same lead foot being
forward so if I'm here and I come off to
the side you can see I have the same
lead foot board that makes it Hannie
choukaku or a 45 step I could switch my
feet when I go to that same honey
position so you have gone to hug me
by switching my feet and we call this
sankaku which is triangles just a
triangular position to step like this I
could come all the way off to the side
coming into that heat bellamy position
and this is just choukaku so by moving
myself off to the side I have a cheap
choukaku
now when doing choukaku you want to
always have your open side towards this
guy so I have my hands in front of me to
defend myself or be offense if I needed
if I stood in like this this would be a
bad way to do it because you can see I'm
not lying to deal with Josh or deal with
John I have to move all the way over
here and so that's another timing
creates a lot of difficulty for me so
anytime we go into a choukaku my open
side is towards the person I'm dealing
with right and that's a choukaku I can
also make a silk thermal warning so turn
to the outside like this so I'm letting
my body turned to the outside of Josh so
easy soak the boys all the time now if
you look at my my Asha Tsubaki just my
footwork right now
that's a 10 con but in relation to Josh
it's so full warning we'll talk about
later why you can't always say that's
just 10 con because sylco more it can be
different things in different positions
I also could do an eg more and turn it
to the inside like this I'm moving
inside of Josh now this might look like
a really weird action but I'm going to
show you why the theory of Aikido needs
this action it's actually super martial
and super useful but when you look at it
right now it's a stupid way to turn
there's a really good reason why we have
to have eating or velorek movements
the more I move it and now what I want
to say a second ago would just eating me
he needs another tiny link oh right
trying to enter right in behind Josh I'm
sliding it maybe it would move just a
little bit more than Center perfect okay
so what I'm making eating me I'm sliding
in here behind this guy now those can
all be done from Yahoo enemies we just
did also Jocelyn is sin honey one more
time for me
perfect we could do these same things
from I honey so here's hi honey here's a
bunch of gaku a shukaku
a son Kaku a soap bubble art and fuchi
Warren and me now these things would
never be done static jaw should be
moving at me and I'm trying to bury the
line right so we also need to practice
these keen or Nagata at a certain point
but to get started these will kind of
give you the ideas of the positions we
use in Aikido and an important like a
way to grade them right so anytime I
move on me without on me that's bad hey
honey is the first position where I
could start to work and I'm okay at
least don't need to worry totally about
my feet but that's still not a great
position a choukaku
is a way better position and et me is
the best position we can make so we're
always trying to work those positions
and then the way we get to those
positions is the tiny Oh Hank oh that we
practice these are core to understanding
Aikido first you have to have good eye
shoe sabaki oh and you have good
actually Tsubaki you can start to move
to relational positions once you can do
this keyhole like we just did real basic
then you should be able to move into
kena Nagato and then you can move into
actual awash say so how do we make a
wash say to defend ourselves and people
are coming for us this is the basic town
of Hanko in positions used in Aikido and
Christopher Hine thanks for watching